bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir c'est
vous Olivier marlès bonsoir merci d'être
là patron des républicains à l'Assemblée
depuis un an déjà c'est un job pas
facile 62 députés autant d'électrons
libres mais c'est un job stratégique
puisque vous jouez avec votre groupe les
arbitres dans cette assemblée menacée
d'immobilisme on va y revenir longuement
dans la deuxième partie mais on commence
ce soir avec deux mots intelligence
artificielle c'est sans doute l'enjeu du
siècle de mots qui fascine autant qu'ils
inquiète alors deux mots dans toutes les
têtes aujourd'hui au salon vivatech qui
s'est ouvert Porte de Versailles
Emmanuel Macron y était il veut à la
fois promouvoir et réguler l'IA mais
est-ce seulement possible sommes-nous
prêts à l'intelligence artificielle
grand débat dans un instant avec mes
invités avant de retrouver les
affranchis pour leur parti pris et puis
d'un Bourbon Express ce soir record de
rappel à l'ordre un an après et bien on
verra cela avec Stéphanie des pierres
toujours cette spéciale cette semaine un
an après la nouvelle Assemblée voilà
pour le programme vous me suivez ma
annexe ça vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
pour les uns le remplacement de l'humain
par la machine est en marche pour les
autres c'est la promesse d'une
émancipation l'intelligence artificielle
est déjà là dans notre quotidien mais la
révolution technologique à venir celle
d'après va-t-elle trop vite alors les
questions sont vertigineuses elles sont
éthiques économiques politiques on va
essayer d'y voir plus clair avec vous
Laurence de Villers bonsoir bonsoir et
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes une grande
spécialiste de ces questions professeur
en informatique à la Sorbonne chercheur
au CNRS auteur des robots émotionnels
aux éditions de l'Observatoire vous
travaillez notamment sur l'interaction
affective avec la machine ça mérite une
explication on y reviendra bonsoir
Julien maldonato bienvenue vous êtes
associés chez Deloitte cabinet de
conseils en charge de ces questions
d'innovation vos conseillers les
entreprises de la tech notamment sur lia
bonsoir Nathan de verre ravi de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau vous êtes
philosophe on a besoin d'un peu de
philosophie dans ce débat abyssal vous
avez publié les liens artificiels chez
Albin Michel c'est un roman sur le
métaver enfin bonsoir Anne Le Hainan et
bienvenue vous êtes député horizon du
Morbihan vous êtes membre de la
commission de la défense la guerre et
Léa et bien sont intimement liées on en
dira également un mot Olivier Marleix se
débat nous concerne tous alors n'hésitez
pas à participer ou même interroger nos
invités on commence par planter le décor
lia en deux secondes c'est un défi le
chrono de Blacko tout de suite
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
à toutes et tous alors on a peur on n'a
pas peur faut-il avoir peur de
l'intelligence artificielle donc la
question qu'on se pose ce soir elle est
vraiment pas nouvelle ça nous rajeunit
pas mais il y a 50 ans plus de 50 ans 68
ça l'exprimer qui avait fait un film
donc connaissez au moins le titre 2001
ou 17 l'espace qui racontait l'histoire
donc un ordinateur super intelligent qui
se mettait à tuer tous les astronautes
embarqués avec lui dans un vaisseau
spatial on appelle ça de la science
fiction à l'époque et bien aujourd'hui
c'est un sujet d'actualité et la preuve
il y a 350 experts mais vraiment de haut
niveau même
Altman qui est le patron de on va dire
ça pour dire que bien sans
réglementation très stricte liée pourra
se développer et finir par devenir aussi
dangereux qu'une pandémie qu'une guerre
nucléaire donc avec une menace même pour
l'humanité ils ne sont pas les seuls à
le penser Elon Musk bon bah lui vous le
connaissez il a pas mal de succès à son
crédit bien lui il partage cette crainte
au point de vouloir suspendre pendant
six mois les recherches pour qu'on de
temps de fixer des règles alors
évidemment quels sont les risques c'est
la question qu'on se pose c'est un outil
donc comme tous les outils ils peuvent
être utilisés par des gens mal
intentionnés sauf que là les
conséquences seraient vraiment très
importantes tellement l'outil et
puissant et puis l'autre risque c'est
peut-être un risque plus profond c'est
l'idée que l'intelligence artificielle
pourrait se développer et devenir assez
court terme plus intelligente encore que
l'humanité et donc en venir à nous
prendre une la domination sur nous donc
ça c'est une hypothèse qui peut faire
sourire peut-être mais elle était mise
enfin en tout cas genre Geoffrey Hinton
qui est un des grands pionniers de
l'intelligence artificielle lui donne du
crédit il a même démissionné de chez
Google pour voir parler plus librement
de ce sujet alors c'est un peu difficile
à expliquer moi ma croire ça pouvait
faire sourire je voyais quand je le
disais mais qu'est-ce qui se passerait
si les ordinateurs devenaient plus
intelligents que nous donc il s'exprimer
dans des étudiants à Toronto et il a
essayé de leur raconter une petite
blague pour illustrer ça donc pour bien
comprendre la blague faut se rappeler
qu'un grizzly c'est un ours qui fait 2
mètres de haut et 300 kg
c'est comme si des généticiens se
disaient on va améliorer la race des
grizzly on a déjà réussi à leur donner
un QI de 65 ils savent parler anglais
maintenant et on peut les utiliser pour
un tas de trucs mais on peut faire mieux
et on va leur donner un QI de 210
ça vaut le coup quand même c'est ce
qu'on devrait travailler ça faut pas
arrêter et puis dans le même rapport le
même rapport ils disent que ça pourrait
aussi supprimer 300 millions d'emplois
dans le monde là il faudrait justement
bien on est exactement là-dedans un peu
dans le en même temps qui vous le savez
est un peu le concept phare de notre
président donc il était à Villette cet
après-midi et il a souligné c'est
l'importance durant en même temps
investir à fond et en même temps être
prêt à freiner au cas où ça tourne mal
on l'écoute on est très décroché par
rapport aux Américains et un peu moins
par rapport au chinois donc on doit
investir on doit aller beaucoup plus
vite et beaucoup plus fort et en même
temps il faut qu'on participe de
cette volonté mondiale de réguler l'IA
et voilà et en même temps donc essayez
de concilier les contrats donc je vous
laisse débattre je vous rappelle juste
que il y a 6 mois personnes en tout cas
pas moins savait ce que c'était que
chaque gypity donc peut-être que dans 6
mois il y a un nouveau truc qui va tout
changer mais bon justement on va prendre
le temps de démêler tout ça merci
beaucoup Stéphane je vais commencer par
ma rater sur les mots avec vous Laurence
de Villers intelligence artificielle de
quoi parle-t-on précisément déjà le mot
intelligent on pourrait se demander
pourquoi on utilise une capacité humaine
pour qualifier ses capacités là
calculantes mais qui n'ont pas d'émotion
ni de morale ni de conscience oui ce
n'est pas l'intelligence enfin c'était
un fantasme des premiers concepteurs de
ces machines qui voulaient donner des
capacités cognitives à une machine
capable de percevoir de raisonner de
générer des du texte et de faire des
actions mais ce n'est pas l'intelligence
c'est l'imitation
avec certains biais et donc il faut
vraiment comprendre que le point de vue
de la machine c'est vraiment du calcul
uniquement des calculs statistiques
probabiliste donc elle ne peut pas
reproduire l'intelligence humaine ça
c'est non pas du tout et quand on parle
de réseau neurones il y a là une
ambiguïté en fait dans ces systèmes on
utilise effectivement ce qu'on appelle
des neurones que qu'on représente en
fait par des formules mathématiques et
qui sont très simples et ça correspond
peut-être à une simulation très simple
d'un de nos types de neurones qui sont
dans la cornée c'est tout notre cerveau
on a une centaine de neurones avec des
hiérarchies très complexes or ces
systèmes sont extrêmement simples et
puis nous les concevons nous les
ordonnons donc l'intelligence
artificielle c'est surtout le fait de
pouvoir apprendre dans ces machines un
certain nombre de choses alors on
apprend à discriminer reconnaître des
formes on apprend à générer c'est le cas
de ce qui du cœur de chat GPT alors
juste pas seulement une idée générative
qui est aussi un conversation il faut
que vous nous expliquiez pourquoi on a
franchi un palier déterminant avec
tchadji Kitty on comprend que on est
voilà à l'aube de quelque chose de
nouveau nous parle de robots
conversationnel tout le monde l'utilise
soit pour des dissertations il y a des
pays qui déjà interdisent des
universités on doit se méfier je crois
d'ailleurs que son son inventeur son
patron ça malthman dit attention on
tient il est bienveillant on lui a mis
des verrous moraux notamment qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez machine est ni
bienveillante ni malveillante elle n'a
pas du tout cette aptitude à avoir des
considérations morales ou des intentions
néfastes c'est un outil qui calcule
encore une fois en quoi c'est un palier
de chat Jipi
pour nous chercheurs c'est une
continuité je travaille sur les réseaux
de neurones depuis ma thèse en 92
ensuite nous avons fait des réseaux
récurrents on fait on progresser ces
systèmes qui sont des Transformers par
exemple qu'on utilise dans ou dans dans
chat GPT dans le cœur
modèle qui fascine tout le monde ce sont
des systèmes qu'on a dans les mains
depuis 2017 et qui ne sont absolument
pas magiques ils apprennent on prend des
phrases et on préfère c'est une
multitude de phrases et on enlève un mot
et on apprend tous les liens après dire
ce mot en fait tous les liens possibles
pour que ce mot soit compris non pas
dans son acception de mots parce que la
machine connaît rien mais elle
représente sous forme d'un vecteur qui
va mémoriser tous les contextes dans
lequel on peut trouver ce mot et comme
il y a des milliards de données cette
machine a une puissance elle est capable
de faire de la syntaxe correctement elle
est capable d'enchaîner les choses qui
pour nous sont une illusion de
sémantique elle est capable de se
tromper et c'est capable de se tromper
elle est capable de donner un certain
nombre de fausses informations elle fait
des hallucinations terribles donc il
faut faire très attention je crois parce
qu'il y a quand ça Malta dit qu'il faut
réguler maintenant il aimerait bien que
tout le monde régule parce que lui il
est sur la patron lorsque
nous dit attention j'ai quitté Google
bah il aurait pu se réveiller avant
parce que nous avons des chercheurs bien
connus Margaret Mitchell timide gebruck
qui ont fait un article en 2021 des
criant les biais de discrimination qui
avait dans ces systèmes et disons
attention nous sommes en train de jouer
à l'apprent ils ont raison d'alerter
mais c'est un peu tard c'est ça non
c'est une modification je pense que lui
c'est avant tout pour sa carrière ça
fait partie de la stratégie c'est ça et
quand tu as Elon Musk ça c'est le pompon
parce que c'est quand même pas quelqu'un
qui freine en général et là qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait il a dit à tout le monde
arrêtons-nous qu'est-ce qu'il fait en
même temps il crée une société pour
aller plus vite de son côté cette
hypocrisie totale moi je dis que ça
c'est de la géopolitique ça n'a rien à
voir avec de la technologie on vous fait
croire en fait que il y a une énorme un
énorme potentiel mais bon je quitte la
Raphaël Enthoven qui s'est livré à cet
exercice de philosophe la rédaction de
philosophie avec chat GPT qui se livrait
même exercice bon il y a pas photo tout
de suite on décèle que il y a une
machine d'un côté c'est pas très fin
et qui fait le tri entre le vrai du faux
il n'y a pas aujourd'hui un moyen
d'empêcher de chez dibiti dire des fake
news une sorte de système on travaille
là-dessus on recherche justement l'idée
c'est d'aller plus loin par exemple chat
j'ai pété et fait en anglais hein c'est
des données à 80 % en anglais donc elles
ont une influence de par les opinions
qui sont dans ces textes de par la
syntaxe sur finalement ce qu'on va
générer en français si je l'optimise que
fait faire barre de Google l'optimiser
sur le français je suis désolé pourquoi
on prend un prêt train mordle
c'est-à-dire ce gros cœur qui a pris sur
des milliards de données en anglais il y
a là une manipulation d'un langage
dominant sur finalement ce que nous
sommes et cette prise
cette guerre ouverte existe vraiment je
quitte là il y a la semaine dernière un
énorme la plus grande conférence dans ce
domaine des large engagement de
traitement automatique de la langue et
bien nous étions
15 français 93 européens contre une
masse de chercheurs asiatiques qui
étaient deux fois plus nombreux que les
chercheurs américains donc il faut bien
comprendre que nous sommes sur un vrai
tournant de capacité à prendre en compte
les choses il faut absolument investir
sur la recherche et garder nos
chercheurs parce que non seulement il y
avait beaucoup de chercheurs mais il y
avait pas de société non plus il y avait
deux sociétés européennes présentes
orange et une société anglaise on y
reviendra est-ce qu'on a notre chat
chipiti à nous français ou européens
Nathan de verre vous qui êtes à la fois
philosophe et enseignant ce qui est un
peu vertigineuse ce sont des images
mi-journées là toutes ces images qui ont
circulé alors peut-être que certains
arrivent à déceler le côté complètement
fabriqué mais très très vite demain ce
sera impossible on est capable de vivre
dans ce monde là où la frontière entre
le vrai du faux n'existe plus on est
armé pour ça aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que que ces images étaient
extrêmement saisissantes d'abord parce
qu'il y avait cet effet de mirage où il
était difficile de savoir faire la part
des choses si bien que parfois
d'ailleurs on a pu avoir l'impression
que des images étaient vraies récemment
il y a une photo une fausse photographie
de Rimbaud qui a énormément circuler sur
sur Internet rimbo jeune et bon sauf si
on savait que c'était pas possible que
cette photo était prise on pouvait
tomber dans le panneau et en même temps
ces images elles sont toujours faites
bon par une intelligence artificielle
mais parce que un être humain derrière a
demandé à l'intelligence artificielle de
concevoir cette image avec un message
précis prenons l'exemple de l'image très
célèbre du pape avec la fameuse doudoune
très très mode et très excentrique et
évidemment que la personne qui a demandé
à l'intelligence artificielle de générer
cette image c'était parce qu'en fait
elle représente quelque chose de très
profond là en l'occurrence le lien entre
la papauté qui est une institution
si vous voulez hors du temps hors de la
réalité immédiate et qui en même temps
est une institution qui de la pointe de
toute la communication moderne et qui
est une icône de la mode est humaine
c'est ça que vous voulez le dire ça il
faut jamais l'oublier exactement il y a
toujours des humains derrière et
d'ailleurs pour les fake news c'est la
même manière je veux dire c'est toujours
des êtres humains derrière qui créent
des fake news en sachant que tel ou tel
a plus ou moins de chance de se répandre
dans l'opinion et d'être cru par des
gens alors vous vous faites partie vous
êtes enseignant j'imagine que voilà vous
avez quelques relations actuelles
difficiles vous l'avez testé vous avez
peut-être des élèves qui ont envie d'y
recourir on a tort de vouloir brider ça
c'est un bel outil qui peut nous
permettre de je sais pas mieux
travailler ou au contraire faut des
verrouses très vite je pense qu'on on
l'a tort de poser le débat sur ce genre
d'affect qui est l'affecte de la crainte
face à une révolution technologique on
aurait tort de dire que ça ne change
rien c'est évidemment une révolution
majeure face à chat gepetty quand on
l'utilise la première question qu'on
peut se poser si on demande moi par
exemple j'avais un mail administratif
que j'arrivais pas à écrire et le chat
gipity a écrit beaucoup mieux que moi
tout de suite et la première question
que je me suis posé c'était de me dire
comment se fait-il que Tchad et pitty
puisse penser mieux que moi et que je
n'ai pas le monopole de de l'esprit
enfin et pas moi mais que l'être humain
n'est pas le monopole de son esprit mais
je pense qu'il faut retourner la
question la poser à l'envers c'est pas
comment se fait-il que tu me rampe me
ressemble mais comment moi je peux
ressembler à ce que fait une machine ça
veut dire qu'en fait une révolution
technologique
est toujours un miroir d'une
représentation de la manière dont
l'humain fonctionne je vais vous donner
un exemple au 19e siècle je caricature
un petit peu mais la révolution
industrielle elle a eu un effet majeur
c'est qu'elle a consisté à mécaniser le
travail manuel jusqu’alors pendant très
longtemps toute la théorie d'Aristote
sur la main la main et le propre de
l'homme parce que l'homme a un outil de
tous les outils et les animaux ont des
pattes pas des mains etc et la
révolution industrielle a dit à l'homme
c'est une grande blessure narcissique tu
n'as pas le monopole de ta main puisque
une machine peut et une machine peut le
faire beaucoup mieux que toi de la même
manière qu'il y aura peut-être des
intelligences artificielles plus
intelligentes que nous mais la
révolution industrielle ça a été la
baisse du temps de travail ça a été la
découverte de l'épanouissement ça a été
la diminution de la de le labeur pénible
de la fatigue ça a été des évolutions
politiques à long terme mais tout à fait
libératrice donc il faut savoir au fond
l'accompagner peut-être même réfléchir à
quel modèle de société voilà on veut par
rapport à cette technologie mais pas en
avoir peur et immédiatement vouloir la
limiter c'est ça il faut savoir à mon
avis se dire que la révélation qu'il y a
c'est de se dire qu'une grande partie de
notre vie intellectuelle et au sens
ontologique du terme mécanisable
c'est-à-dire que et à partir de là ça
invite à repenser aussi notre travail
intellectuel et notre vie intellectuelle
alors la députée que vous êtes parce
qu'on parle de régulation il se trouve
que ce débat vivatech il arrive aussi
avec la Commission européenne qui
travaille sur un projet d'encadrement de
liens qui sera proposé au Parlement
européen et aux États membres vous voyez
des choses comment
il faut immédiatement réfléchir aux
limites aux limites éthiques notamment
ou c'est pas forcément quelque chose qui
qui doit être ur
alors tout d'abord l'humanité notre
monde a connu plusieurs révolutions je
dirais technologiques je dirais que
c'est une parmi d'autres c'est la suite
de ce qui s'est passé depuis des siècles
les plus vertigineuses non elle est plus
vertigineuse parce que ça va en fait
très très vite et qu'on maîtrise
peut-être moins les choses parce que
c'est très virtuel c'est c'est un
palpable d'une certaine manière mais
quand le président de la République
parle de en même temps il est important
qu'on ait cette position la France ne
peut pas puisque nous avons l'ambition
d'être une nation
plutôt en avance en Europe sur ces
sujets de l'intelligence artificielle on
ne peut pas à la fois j'irai pousser
investir dans la recherche dans la
formation dans dans la technologie donc
accompagner les startups les grands
groupes qui travaillent sur ce sujet et
puis sans contenter c'est pas
raisonnable donc le en même temps il est
au contraire je dirais sérieux étant
donné le sujet à la fois il faut
investir et on a mis sur la table 2
milliards et 2030 donc en 2030 on y
croit et on veut les champions en Europe
sur le sujet mais en même temps
excusez-moi j'utilise le terme quand
même mais en même temps il faut qu'on ne
se poser les questions des valeurs de
comment la feuille de route qu'elle
ambition je dirais presque
d'objectifs
de moyens nous avons pour la France
c'est-à-dire l'écrire la France et
l'Europe parce que ça c'est j'allais
dire avec nos partenaires européens les
députés européens c'est tout frais
viennent de décider justement de réguler
donc en même temps il est nécessaire que
la France puisse avoir également une une
vraie réflexion sur la régulation et
c'est ce que nous allons bien sûr faire
et ce sujet dans le barreau a commencé à
alors on va voir parce que ça semble
déjà compliqué il faudrait que les
IA les entreprises jouent le lieu à quoi
ça peut ressembler une régulation mais
on a l'impression de parler quand même
des risques il faut quand même dire que
d'abord c'est déjà dans notre quotidien
il y a aujourd'hui dans dans nos
téléphones dans la médecine dans les
montres connectées et ça nous fait faire
quand même de sacrées économies
d'échelle de temps c'est un progrès on
peut utiliser ce mot c'est un progrès
dans le sens où comme pour rejoindre ce
que disait Laurence dans la continuité
de tout ce qu'on a amélioré dans dans
les organisations qu'elle soit publique
ou privées nous on accompagne les
horizons depuis 200 ans
on va et notamment on a vécu des
révolutions notamment celle de
l'industriel quand le secteur apparu les
économies de service les économies
autour de la connaissance sont sortis de
terre on a eu l'apparition de
l'informatique qui a booster tout ça et
vous le disiez lia est apparu assez vite
finalement dans ses premières formes
elle est plus sophistiquée elle est plus
efficace elle est plus performante et
donc dans ses services on les rend mieux
pour la fin des fins le consommateur ou
le citoyen il a accès à plus
d'informations plus vite avec les
billets les tout ce qu'on a vu dans
lesquels on peut avoir le plus
d'ambition d'espoir c'est la médecine la
fameuse médecine prédictive qui nous
permet d'anticiper les probabilités
d'avoir tel ou telle pathologie ça
c'était extraordinaire il y a ce champ
là qui est déjà bien travaillé plus le
champ de la créativité en médecine c'est
à dire qu'effectivement je rejoins
Laurent sur le fait que lia actuellement
elle est très bête elle a pas confiance
de ce qu'elle fait en revanche elle peut
aider des chercheurs j'aimerais bien
être capable voilà comme les algorithmes
sur 500 millions de données pouvoir
sortir elle est très bête elle est très
bête en tout cas c'est des choses que
moi cognitivement je suis pas capable de
faire
donner pour un pense à l'homme en
revanche elle peut aider à
désassemblages moléculaires elle peut
aider à accélérer la recherche de
traitement que ce soit donc
effectivement curatif où on a parlé de
la gestion des risques en préventifs
donc essayer d'identifier avant que ça
n'arrive certaines pathologies donc il y
a un champ énorme de de Kiki déjà touché
dans plein de domaines de la médecine et
qui va s'accélérer parce qu'on a la
chance vous le disiez ce qui change
quand même c'est cette excellent on l'a
vu dans les chiffres cette accélération
d'adoption qui sont
il y a quelques dizaines d'années un peu
moins facile à déployer aujourd'hui on
les déploie un peu plus vite dans les
organisations encore une fois qu'elle se
publie plus je vous fais réagir dans un
instant mais je voudrais vérifier une
chose parce qu'on en parlait beaucoup
avec mon équipe cet après-midi il y a
generative il y a générale c'est quoi le
général c'est les tables d'après
Laurence de Villers ça correspond à quoi
ça existe déjà non
en anglais il y a générale c'est il n'y
a conscience il n'y a qui c'est qui
capable de raisonner sur beaucoup de
sujets si on n'est pas du tout sur ces
ça n'existe pas non non et ça n'existera
pas comme ça il y a pas du tout ça
n'existera pas parce que vous empêcher
ou parce que c'est pardon ça n'existera
pas parce qu'on va l'empêcher ou ça
n'existera pas parce que
technologiquement ça n'est pas possible
aujourd'hui non ça ne résonne pas du
tout on fait toujours un parallèle avec
l'humain donc c'est très bien que ça
soit un miroir de nous-mêmes et qu'on
puisse réfléchir sur nous grâce à cela
mais ça n'a rien à voir c'est un système
qui apprend en répétant énormément de
choses avec des milliards de données un
enfant il met sa main il sent que c'est
chaud il a compris que ça brûlait et
c'est tout et hop ça a pas de corps ça a
pas de sens ça a pas l'intention ça a
pas de connotus de d'intention de vie
d'appétit de vie il y a rien dans tout
ça par contre nous on a l'illusion en
voyant cette machine comme vous le dites
avec ces termes exacerbée de ses
fantastique tout cela on a l'illusion
que il connaît des choses mieux que nous
donc sur on se fait avoir sur la
projection de connaissances on se fait
avoir sur la projection d'affect parce
que cette machine dit je nous et nous
parle de façon intense à nous-mêmes et
on est peut-être isolé donc on va se
faire manipuler assez facilement et
d'autre part elle a aussi
peut-être des qualités morales on va lui
en trouver ce qui n'est pas vrai du tout
elle a pas du tout de qualité morale
elle est capable de vous dire de sauter
par la fenêtre donc le diable est dans
les détails quand même il faut faire
très attention c'est une machine qui
crée qui crée des choses alors c'est pas
de la création sens humain mais qui est
capable de générer des formes des
séquences nouvelles des hallucinations
même alors de temps en temps ça tombe
très bien c'est des émergences de
comportements comme les nôtres mais de
temps en temps avec la même facilité ça
peut faire émerger les choses totalement
dangereuses pour nous au fond le plus
dangereux c'est qui s'empare de ces
outils là et c'est là que la question
elle devient politique au lieu Marleix
c'est pas l'outil c'est ce qu'on en fait
oui c'est pas nouveau Rabelais il y a
quelques siècles disait sur sa
conscience n'est que ruines de l'âme non
il y a quand même des espoirs absolument
formidables enfin on parlait de domaine
de la de la médecine je viens d'avoir lu
dans la presse et quelques jours
des avancées faites notamment une
entreprise que d'associés à racheté qui
permet de d'identifier l'origine d'un
cancer quand il s'agit d'un cancer
diffus dont on connaît pas le cancer
primitif et qui permettent désormais de
d'identifier ce qui est l'origine quel
est l'organe concerné et de le traiter
et donc permettre aux gens d'avoir de
guérir leur cancers là ou autrefois on
ne savait absolument pas le faire vous
avez des traitements très très lourds
donc c'est quand même des espaces de
progrès absolument en politique je vais
vous montrer juste un tout petit clip
peut-être que vous l'avez vu sur vos sur
vos réseaux Éric Zemmour un petit
extrait regardez
[Musique]
voilà ça dure beaucoup plus longtemps
mais il a expliqué aujourd'hui sur les
réseaux sociaux que c'était le premier
clip politique entièrement 100%
Ia on voit bien que c'est pas le vrai
Emmanuel Macron vous pourriez faire ça
vous retrouvez ça bien ou pas le premier
risque aujourd'hui c'est celui
effectivement de l'utilisation de de
l'outil on a déjà vu en politique avec
le scandale Cambridge Analytica
où on collecte des données on va les
utiliser on va cibler les gens qu'on
veut influencer manipuler donc pour
l'instant le premier danger IMA parce
que je retourne de ce qu'on a dit c'est
que
derrière il y a toujours un pilote et
celui qui a le monopole de la création
de la créativité ça reste l'humain donc
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt rassurant la
vraie question à laquelle moi je ne sais
pas du tout répondre c'est ce que un
jour
l'ordinateur supercalculateur peut
considérer que son intelligence est
supérieur à celui qui lui donne des
ordres et prendre ça dans les films de
science-fiction c'est ça c'est le pilote
qui dit des décisions ne sont pas ne
sont pas les bonnes et donc j'impose
finalement une autre décision qui décide
de vous éliminer quoi
j'ai pété deux la même personne qui nous
a mis dans les mains j'ai pété 3.5
Richard GPT avait dit c'est trop
dangereux il faut pas le partager de la
même façon lambda qui est dans bar de
celui de Google il ne voulait pas le
partager parce qu'il pensait que c'était
dangereux pourquoi par cette
vulnérabilité qu'on a entendre une
machine qui parle comme nous et par
contre sur les vidéos ce que vous ayez
tout à l'heure il est urgent de
normaliser les choses c'est-à-dire de
mettre ce qu'on appelle des filigranes
savoir que l'image qu'on voit est en
fait une construction à partir d'un
énorme travail d'éducation aussi un
travail d'adaptation il faut normaliser
cela on est allé quand même à vivatech
et je vous donne la parole juste après
Nathan de verre parce que elle est
partout il y a on en a parlé la santé
mais aussi l'urbanisme ou encore la
sécurité c'est un sujet de Pierre
Michael Carniel avec Léa Jouanno
regarder tour d'horizon de ce qu'on fait
en France notamment
ici il n'y a pas une seule innovation
sans une touche d'intelligence
artificielle des nouveaux moyens de
paiement pour l'inclusion des
non-voyants ou bien cette voiture qui
stocke l'électricité lorsqu'elle est
moins chère chez Bionic système c'est un
exosquelette qui soulage ceux qui
portent de grosses charges
on a une intelligence artificielle dans
nos produits qui fait ce qu'on appelle
du machine learning donc il va s'adapter
à la personne adapter les réglages des
grosses squelette en fonction de la
personne on a tous des tailles des
hauteurs des morphologies des façons de
se baisser de soulever différentes donc
là grâce au moteur la personne 80% du
poids et éliminer sur son corps au
niveau du ressenti c'est comme si on
portait 5 6 kg alors que la caisse fait
plus de 20 kg quoi la Poste
l'expérimente déjà dans ses services du
côté de la SNCF la start-up twenty to
oeuvre pour une meilleure sécurité mais
on peut para
métrer de manière à arrêter les trains
et qui est pas d'accident et donc notre
job c'est que les plus de 50 000 caméras
de la SNCF soit manager par Unia et
qu'on détecte les incidents les flux de
personnes les malaises et tout autre cas
atypique en fait qui peuvent arriver
vivatech est un salon qui se veut
international avec plus de 30 pays
représentés car l'intelligence
artificielle est au cœur de la guerre de
l'innovation mais la France n'est pas si
mal placée selon cette experte
pour l'intelligence artificielle en tant
que telle
on est déjà
très la
main pressée super importante ça peut
être aussi dans la lutte contre la
fraude dans le secteur de la finance il
y a déjà beaucoup de solutions dia après
c'est sur les IA générative donc avec
les tchadjipiti qu'on a découvert un peu
comme ça de manière spectaculaire où là
on attend des démonstrations françaises
pour que la France comble une partie de
son retard le député Renaissance Paul
midi vient de remettre au gouvernement
un rapport pour soutenir les startups
des propositions pouvant s’élever
jusqu'à 3 milliards d'euros elles seront
bientôt débattues dans l'hémicycle
voilà Nathan de verre il y a des
opportunités c'est voilà une révolution
marche c'est des gens très émouvant de
voir tout ce qu'on va ce qu'on va faire
ce qu'il faut dire aussi c'est que on
sera peut-être pas remplacé par les
robots de mains tous mais certains
métiers vont disparaître et ça est-ce
qu'on est aussi capable de s'adapter à
cette transition là oui certains métiers
vont en tout cas il va y avoir un
bouleversement de la société et un
bouleversement professionnel c'est
pourquoi à mon avis la question est
moins de savoir si ça va tomber entre
des bonnes mains ou des mauvaises mains
entre guillemets que de savoir si cette
révolution technologique va être
accompagnée d'un vrai débat si vous
voulez sur ces implications les métiers
le mien par exemple il est menacé
l'enquêteur le mathématicien
s'intéressant parce que ce sont des
métiers quand même à assez qualifiés en
tout cas c'est le c'est le back office
parce que les métiers manuels eux ils
sont pas menacés peut-être que pour une
fois il y a une forme de justice sociale
là-dedans mais l'accompagnement alors on
est prêt comment
ça me semble voilà c'est urgent de se
poser toutes ces questions madame la
députée
sur ces métiers il y a quand même au
niveau de des métiers manuels
l'intelligence artificielle va quand
même alléger un certain nombre de tâches
notamment dans vous qui êtes consultant
qui accompagnent les entreprises dans
les industries vont enlever on supprimer
des tâches que l'homme fait actuellement
sur sur des usines dans des dans des
industries c'est la machine qu'il fera
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle donc
quand même il y aura un impact sur
l'industrie malgré tout oui il y a un
gros impact sur beaucoup de métiers il y
aura peut-être de nouveaux métiers c'est
une évidence mais ce temps là cette
transition là qui la pense où sont où
sont les idées là pour éviter le pire
une vraie vraie choc social pour les
premiers concernés c'est justement ce
qui est en train de se faire
actuellement il faut pas qu'on rate le
train justement c'est à la fois
développé inciter accompagner investir
et puis
et bien en même temps avoir conscience
quand même des impacts et des travers
que cela peut représenter pour les
accompagner et notamment il y a un sujet
je pense que vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure très rapidement il va falloir
accompagner la les citoyens et les
éduquer sur ce qu'est l'intelligence
artificielle pour ne pas ce qui est cet
angoisse permanente et cette peur de
quelque chose qui qui finalement
pourraient représenter un danger pour
eux 500 millions pour l'instant sur la
table et du quai faire tout ça et puis
comme dit Madame avertir quand c'est la
machine qui fait c'est très important et
nous on travaille déjà sur le sujet avec
le gouvernement alors comme on vous
travaillez dans le privé pour gérer les
transitions à venir les fameuses
destructions créatrices
et comme je disais il y a 200 ans on
s'attendait pas à sortir des champs pour
se retrouver dans derrière des écrans
comme beaucoup de gens dans les dans les
sociétés de service que ce soit dans la
banque dans l'assurance par exemple les
avocats sont menacés
menacées en tout cas ils vont changer et
ils vont changer de métier dans les
tâches
mais comme sur le compte c'est un très
bon exemple parce qu'on parler tout à
l'heure de des fake des faux on a
justement on a été créé pour certifier
les comptes de la société nationale le
chemin de fer à l'époque où personne
voulait investir dans la révolution
israélienne anglaise on a on a permis de
rassurer et ce métier-là de rassurance
de certifier les choses on peut être
filigrane les signatures qu'on peut
intégrer dans ce qui serait généré par
l'IA il va falloir effectivement s'étire
de confiance les renouveler dans leur
métier les avocats les prolonger on est
vraiment dans des outils qui amplifient
l'humain comme encore une fois tous les
outils qu'on a connus et ce qui est
merveilleux c'est que on va toujours
plus loin et on tire finalement l'humain
vers encore
plus haut en termes de d'épanouissement
je vais vous donner le mot de la fin bon
la France n'est pas à la traîne si j'ai
bien compris en matière dia même si on
n'a pas encore on attend il y a Bloom
c'est ça je crois
c'est franco-américain puisque ce sont
des politiciens qui sont à New York qui
l'ont monté il continue mais il y a un
énorme projet européen qui est en train
d'être
décidés
de mutualiser les efforts et de faire
des verticales sur différents métiers
pour accumuler des données et faire des
grands modèles de langage monolingues
francophones ou multilingue sur
certaines tâches mais avec conscience de
ce qu'on a l'accompagnement on parlait
d'éducation on parlait d'adaptation de
nouveaux métiers mais des métiers qui
vont disparaître ça passe faire du jour
au lendemain mais vous trouvez que la
volonté politique la prise de conscience
est là moi je le en même temps sur
l'éducation je l'entends pas
j'essaie je suis président d'une
fondation la Fondation Blaise Pascal qui
est qui vient de les grands métiers du
numérique enfin le CNRS l'INRIA les
grandes universités on ne voit pas
l'effort qui est fait à l'école pour les
petits j'entends et je pense que c'est
quand on est petit qu'on doit apprendre
les concepts de l'IA et non pas de coder
on nous a parlé du code en 5e moi je
fais des capsules il y a éthiques j'ai
été financée par la MAIF ou par d'autres
acteurs que je vais chercher et on fait
des dessus ou les enfants parlent aux
enfants sur des concepts comme la
dopamine la prise de la tension le fait
qu'on reste beaucoup de temps devant ces
machines et si les expliquer simplement
avec quand même des mots importants et
faire que les enfants débattent on veut
des débats de citoyens il faut des
débats à l'école il faut que les enfants
apprennent à débattre le mot de la fin
allez puisque vous êtes enseignants vous
enseignez la philosophie
ce débat il est il existe on peut y
croire on a quelques raisons d'espérer
parce qu'on aille vite quand même oui
tout à fait alors je pense qu'il y aura
toujours un décalage profond entre ce
qu'on appelle intelligence artificielle
et l'esprit humain c'est-à-dire qu'en
philosophie ce qu'on appelle la
différence entre la conscience
fonctionnelle relationnelle et la
conscience phénoménale l'effet que ça
nous fait d'être là tous ensemble
discuter de s'écouter et ça aucune
machine au sens ontologique du terme ne
pourra jamais ni les prouver ni le
ressentir ni l'exprimer et ben c'est
tant mieux on s'arrête là merci beaucoup
c'était passionnant de vous écouter
merci d'être venu débattre sur LCP vous
restez avec moi Olivier Marle dans une
dizaine de minutes les parties pris de
nos affranchis ce soir Carole Barjon de
Lobbes s'interroge sur un grand silence
celui de la gauche sur l'immigration
Isabelle Lasserre du Figaro revient sur
la contre-offensive au crime ukrainienne
qui a commencé il y a quelques jours et
puis d'un bonbon Express ce soir de quoi
parle-t-on Stéphanie on parle du chahut
à l'Assemblée et des sanctions records
qu'ils provoque merci Stéphanie
Despierre à tout à l'heure mesdames mais
d'abord on parle un peu de vous et de
votre groupe Olivier marlès comment
fait-on pour piloter 62 députés les
républicains lorsqu'il n'en font qu'à
leur tête on voit ça dans l'invitation
de Hélène Bonduelle et on en discute
ensemble juste après
si on vous invite Olivier Marleix c'est
que les républicains le groupe que vous
présidez à l'Assemblée nationale et
depuis un an au centre du jeu
parlementaire sans les LR aucune
majorité possible votre groupe peut
faire basculer les textes au cas par cas
pourtant avec seulement 62 députés vous
arriviez presque en catimini au Palais
Bourbon en juin dernier et perdez votre
place de première opposants nous sommes
un groupe d'opposition mais nous
entendons profiter de la de la situation
de la configuration étonnante de
l'Assemblée pour être un groupe
d'opposition qui défend qui se bat pour
obtenir des avancées pour les Français
doté d'un solide parcours politique
Olivier marlex vous entrez à l'Assemblée
comme député en 2012 inconnu du grand
public jusqu'à ce poste stratégique à la
tête des républicains un groupe pivot
sur le nucléaire sur l'assurance chômage
par exemple il soutient le gouvernement
mais tout ce corps avec la réforme des
retraites un recul de l'âge de départ
pourtant défendu par la droite depuis
toujours mais qui va faire avancer les
républicains en ordre dispersé à la tête
de cette fronde Aurélien Pradier jeune
député du lot
est-ce que le gouvernement à l'intention
d'assurer à toutes celles et ceux en
carrière longue avant 21 ans qui ne
feront pas plus de 43 annuités
du collectif pas normal que
une position qui n'est pas celle de la
majorité de leurs collègues aille
[Musique]
perturbé on va dire le message exprimé
par notre famille politique
autant un tiers des républicains votera
la motion de censure contre le
gouvernement votre groupe a joué avec
les nerfs de la majorité sur les
retraites il repart à la charge sur
l'immigration l'un de ces thèmes de
prédilection alors qu'un texte étant
préparation côté gouvernement vous
dégainer les premiers et déposez pas
moins de deux propositions de loi sur le
sujet ça fait bientôt un an que le
gouvernement change d'avis avec un texte
qui a plutôt tendance à vouloir
assouplir les règles considère en
réalité notre point de vue qu'il faut
durcir les règles fixer des quotas de
migrants remettre les peines planchées
vous avancez une cinquantaine de
propositions et vous forcer la majorité
à se positionner
mais à trop affirmé que cet à prendre ou
à laisser à vouloir préempter le thème
de l'immigration est-ce que vous ne
prenez pas le risque qu'aucun texte ne
soit finalement voté voilà une bonne
questionna ou on a un peu plus de marge
manœuvre allait l'inscrire à l'ordre du
jour le faire inscrire à l'ordre du jour
dès la rentrée de septembre
et donc texte débutera la discussion
débutera au Sénat et donc vous parlez
d'une proposition de loi sénateur c'est
la même déposée par les simultanément
par jour
qui tient sur deux jambes vous les
connaissez mieux que moi fermeté sur les
reconduites à la frontière des étrangers
en situation irrégulière et
l'intégration par le travail parce qu'il
y a une énorme pénurie de recrutement
notamment de restauration et le Medef
réclame c'est ses possibilités de
régularisation au fond c'est un risque
que vous prenez à dire c'est toutes mes
propositions ou rien vous prenez le
risque qu'il n'y ait aucun texte ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'on prendra pas le
risque de voter un texte ou de laisser
passer un texte qui aggraverait la
situation de l'immigration dans notre
pays 500 000 étrangers accueillis cette
année c'est le double de ce qu'on
accueillait quand la droite était au
pouvoir donc pour nous il est hors de
question d'aggraver cette situation
clairement au contraire et on vous
entend et vous êtes en phase avec les
Français là dessus mais il regarde aussi
l'autre jambe cet équilibre du projet de
loi 68% des Français sont favorables à
ce projet de loi c'est-à-dire
intégration par le travail et grosse
fermeté sur la question des étrangers en
situation irrégulière rien n'empêche de
faire plus d'intégration par le travail
c'est possible un taux de chômage y
compris chez les étrangers qui est qui
est important donc ça veut dire quoi
concrètement pour remettre tout le monde
au travail mais on a aujourd'hui des
étrangers sans emploi donc effectivement
on peut on peut déjà le faire travailler
on a 3 millions et demi de chômeurs dans
notre pays donc voilà des étrangers ou
des Français je parle des deux
aujourd'hui il y a 3 millions et demi de
chômeurs dans notre pays dont des
étrangers qui ont des titres de séjour
qui aujourd'hui les étrangers
et pas seulement que dans les grandes
villes ils sont déclarés mais ils n'ont
pas de régularité de séjour régulier
qu'est-ce qu'on fait là
aujourd'hui sont censés être quand même
régulières
dans la restauration 300 000 emplois
vacants à laquelle nous parlons il y a 3
millions de chômeurs dans notre pays
donc on fait avec les chômeurs trouvant
déjà le moyen de
régler
très satisfaisant d'avoir 3 millions de
Français un peu plus au chômage alors
venons-en à votre première année à la
tête des républicains un chef s'est fait
pour chauffer on disait Jacques Chirac
vous avez l'impression d'avoir réussi ça
je pense que
vous trouverez beaucoup d'humilité chez
moi rassurez-vous
oui je pense qu'on revenait de très loin
ils sont présidentielle 4 78%
j'ai pas oublié ce résultat dans
beaucoup de nos circonscriptions je
pense à celle de Pierre Cordier de
maximinot notre candidate a fait aux
alentours de 2%. donc voilà on est tous
arrivé avec avec la gueule de bois et il
a fallu un certain moment de de voilà
pour se remettre après avoir été aussi
sonné
leur victoire avec les dents
la devoir calme et à vous-même n'empêche
que sur les sur les retraites là
avoir envie de refaire de la politique
de manière collective sur la réforme des
retraites c'est la seule réforme qui
Emmanuel Macron a fait depuis 6 ans donc
c'était un peu le l'Himalaya de de la
réforme
oui il y a une divergence qui je crois
était une divergence plutôt de
aller sur la sur la méthode je pense que
vous trouverez personne chez le
républicain qui vous dira que
il faut pas travailler plus pour
personne pour dire ça le programme
présidentiel le pays
je suis moi totalement d'avoir voté
d'avoir soutenu cette réforme et vous
avez eu des frondeurs parce que c'est ça
qui travaille le moins à l'année et le
moins dans une vie c'est faux et tu les
gens qui ont soutenu cette position
Aurélien Pradier j'ai bien compris votre
position je crois que les Français qui
nous regardent bien compris un tiers du
groupe qui vote la censure du
gouvernement comment il peut être encore
au Républicain je comprends pas je pense
qu'il y a pas de désaccord sur sur le
fond sur cette conviction qu'il faut
travailler plus il y avait un vrai
désaccord il y a une espèce de Dilemme
chez nous sur sur par rapport à au
regard qu'on avait sur cette méthode sur
la méthode de maintenance
la division sur ce mot il s'est fait par
rapport à la méthode cette balance
est-ce qu'on sanctionne Macron pour une
méthode très brutale finalement c'est
très forme il a sort du chapeau au mois
d'octobre justement d'un moment si on va
pas voter un amendement déposé par les
sénateurs enfin sans aucune
concentration sans aucun dialogue social
et il y a la méthode mais il y a aussi
structure
en rigolant imaginait de faire
travailler les gens jusqu'à 64 ans donc
cette réforme oui elle est un peu
incompréhensible pour les gens au moment
au moment où elle arrive donc certains
chemins ont surtout venus sanctionner la
méthode je pense que sur le fond en
réalité on est tous conscient qu'il faut
travailler un peu plus la maison a l'air
quand même à l'Assemblée difficile à
suivre ça vous reconnaissez que c'est
pas d'ailleurs sur lequel vous pointer
une division 64% des textes ont été
adoptés grâce aux voix des républicains
à l'Assemblée depuis un an c'est
beaucoup vous le dites d'ailleurs vous
êtes une opposition constructive une
opposition ferme mais constructive
aucune ou presque on a regardé il y en a
deux des propositions de loi LR qui ont
été reprises mais elles étaient pas non
plus fondamentales n'a été reprise ils
sont un gras avec vous non non
propositions de loi vous oubliez de dire
oui les professions spécifiques on a un
enfant on a un ordre du jour initiative
des des groupes d'opposition qui est
extrêmement réduits donc ça c'est normal
ce que j'ai oublié de dire c'est chacun
de ces textes que nous avons voté on l'a
voté parce que nous avons réussi soit à
l'amender et là si on faisait la liste
des amendements repris il y en a
beaucoup plus y compris sur la réforme
des des retraites de retraite le
gouvernement a repris par exemple notre
demande de revaloriser les petites
retraites actuelles en cours pas
seulement les futurs retraités c'est un
million 800000 de retraités en échange
de vos précieux votes il vous renvoie
l'ascenseur
on vote uniquement des textes qu'on a
réussi à amender et puis par rapport aux
autres groupes d'opposition il y a une
différence qu'il faut pas
qu'il faut pas oublier chaque URL a voté
38% des textes aussi donc qui votent
beaucoup plus souvent qu'il ne le disent
oui pourquoi parce que vous oubliez dire
qu'on est majoritaire au Sénat et que
donc les textes qui viennent du Sénat ce
sont les nôtres ils ont été réécrits par
les sénateurs et donc voilà un an après
cette réforme elle a été promulguée aux
forceps on est dans un drôle de moments
politiques quand même le remaniement est
dans toutes les têtes ça flotte un peu
côté majorité vous le qualifiez comment
ce moment-là en attendant de savoir si
on a un nouveau Premier ministre
que la majorité ceux qui postulent se
rapportent qui rêvent d'entrer au
gouvernement ça nous concerne pas on
entend quand même parler de coalition
avec LR c'est non ça fait 6 ans qu'on
répond à cette question avec une
certaine constance voilà nous en donner
ils ont donné qui tue quand même non
notre projet n'a rien à voir avec celui
de d'Emmanuel Macron
pourquoi parce que notre projet
politique n'est pas le même sur des
sujets aussi essentiels que la question
de l'immigration sur tous les sujets
régaliens monsieur Macron a gardé toutes
les lois de Madame Taubira qui ma
connaissance sont pas des lois de droite
sur la question de
trouver des majorités
français des Français après avoir réélu
un peu par défaut je crois le président
de la République ont voulu en quelque
sorte le mettre sous tutelle d'une
Assemblée nationale qu'ils ont voulu
très diverses avec tous les groupes
d'opposition et c'est au gouvernement de
de faire ce grand changement et au
présent rapide et faire ce grand
changement de trouver un peu d'humidité
de trouver un peu de bon sens et un peu
d'écoute et finalement on a réussi sur
des sujets extrêmement importants
regardez le le retour du nucléaire
pendant la République était contre le
nucléaire pendant des années il voulait
fermer en 2018 c'est pas si vieux
finalement à force de de secouer on a
réussi à le faire se convertir au
nucléaire et un texte a été voté qui va
permettre de
de reprendre cette aventure nucléaire
laquelle on avait rompu
on va regarder ça de près puisque
peut-être un dénouement politique dans
les quelques jours pour essayer de
redonner une impulsion on verra ce que
ça donne et si les LR sont au
rendez-vous ou pas vous restez avec moi
c'est l'heure d'accueillir les
affranchis pour leur parti pris au
féminin pluriel ce soir on les accueille
tout de suite
Carole Barjon de l'Obs Isabelle Lasserre
du Figaro bonsoir à toutes les deux
préparez vos parties prix car on
commence comme ça chaque soir par
Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour en
mode spécial un an de la nouvelle
Assemblée nous est raconté ce soir par
Stéphanie des pierres bonsoir Stéphanie
bonsoir et je vous raconte l'histoire
des sanctions contre ces députés
trublions qui chahutent à l'Assemblée
depuis un an leur nombre explose la
dernière sanction date de lundi lors de
la discussion de la motion de censure de
la gauche le député insoumis à Louis
Boyard 23 ans déjà beaucoup de culots
interrompt la première ministre à
plusieurs reprises puis il accuse
carrément la présidente de l'Assemblée
d'être un agent de l'Élysée
est-ce que vous pouvez s'il vous plaît
vous taire monsieur Boyard je vous
demande de vous taire
monsieur Boyard monsieur Boyard je vous
rappelle alors
monsieur Boyard
je prononce à votre rencontre un appel à
lampes avec inscription au procès-verbal
alors Louis Boyard n'a pas démenti ses
propos et la présidente des insoumis à
voler à son secours en expliquant que
dans l'Assemblée nationale par les
forces n'est pas de la violence par les
forces est un exutoire aussi à la colère
de plein de gens dans ce pays Myriam
alors si on regarde un peu tout ça et à
cet événement Boyard c'est que ça coûte
cher une sanction
porte-monnaie exactement on l'a entendu
la présidente de l'Assemblée annonce
d'abord un rappel à l'ordre puis elle
dit cette petite phrase avec inscription
au procès-verbal et bien c'est cette
petite phrase qui coûte cher car cela
veut dire que le député va perdre une
partie de son indemnité luboyard aura
donc un quart de son salaire en moins
pendant un mois soit 1873 euros brut en
moins alors puisqu'on est à l'heure du
bilan puisque ça fait un an déjà quand
il lieu les législatives vous avez fait
les calculs c'est pas le premier député
sanctionné j'imagine non alors on a
regardé d'abord l'ancienne législature
entre 2017 et juin 2022 il y avait eu 16
sanctions mais depuis juillet 2022 on un
an on est Myriam à 91 alors c'est un
chiffre extraordinaire spectaculaire
mais attention parce que 68 députés ont
été punies pour le même fait le même
jour c'est ça qui explique ce chiffre
très élevé ça c'est inédit les insoumis
vous en souvenez avez brandi des
pancartes dans l'hémicycle c'était le 16
mars lors du déclenchement du 49-3 sur
les retraites et il est écrit 64 ans
c'est non et bien l'assemblée elle aussi
a frappé un grand coup et sanctionné
pour tumulte chacun des insoumis qui ce
jour-là portaient un écrite les
sanctions se multiplient sur le podium
des plus sanctionnés on retrouve et bien
on retrouve on a fait les statistiques
c'est indéniablement le groupe insoumis
mais alors attention là encore Myriam
car toutes les sanctions ne se valent
pas il y a quatre niveaux de sévérité
pour la faire des pancartes les insoumis
ont reçu un simple rappel à l'ordre
c'est donc assez symbolique et c'est le
cas pour 90% des punitions Louis Boyard
lui a un rappel avec retenue sur
indemnité on l'a dit comme trois autres
députés insoumis et deux élus rassemblés
rassemblement national pardon cette
année et au sommet des sanctions il y a
l'exclusion alors cela ce n'était arrivé
qu'une seule fois dans toute l'histoire
de la Cinquième République et bien cette
année c'est arrivé deux fois l'insoumis
Thomas porte et le député rassemblement
national à Grégoire defournas ont été
interdits de palais Bourbon pendant 15
jours alors ces sanctions sont-elles
justifiées faut-il être plus dur moins
dur vis-à-vis du comportement des
députés faut-il au contraire protéger la
liberté d'expression des parlementaires
être plus tolérant au nom du combat
politique le débat ne fait que commencer
et vous les adressez directement à
Olivier Marley ces questions 91 c'est
beaucoup c'est pas glorieux et en même
temps est-ce qu'il faudrait
on a vu les images de de mon collègue
Louis Boyard enfin qui est une part de
de théâtre à l'Assemblée qu'une part de
passion c'est très bien et c'est normal
mais là il y a un problème juste
d'éducation comme moi pense toujours
c'est vrai que Monsieur Boyard fait son
numéro
ou quand monsieur Dupont-Moretti fait un
geste qui n'a pas sa place toujours aux
enseignants qui ont qui ont à faire à
tenir des classes de plus en plus
difficiles et je me dis mais quel modèle
on leur donne à l'Assemblée nationale
voilà et donc j'ai un peu honte parfois
j'aime beaucoup plus sage exemplaire
toujours même pendant les retraites
d'être un peu plus digne de de
représenter les Français je pense que ça
demande quand même un petit peu dignité
quoi allez on enchaîne avec vous Carole
alors ce soir vous vouliez nous parler
d'un silence qui vous interpelle qui
vous interroge et ça va vous faire
réagir on était la gauche ne dit pas un
mot de l'immigration
en effet le débat pourtant son plein et
on entend guerre la gauche
social-démocrate sur le sujet depuis des
années et malgré la phrase bien connue
de Michel Rocard la France ne peut pas
accueillir toute la misère du monde
cette question semble tabou pour les
socialistes qu'il s'agisse de ce qui
sont restés au PS avec Olivier Faure ou
bien de ceux qui l'ont quitté sur ce
sujet on a généralement droit ou bien un
silence assourdissant donc à une absence
d'avis sur la question ou bien la
plupart du temps à une dénonciation de
la droiteisation voire de la
localisation des esprits bref de vieux
réflexes qui n'imprime plus vraiment
dans l'opinion en fait alors pourquoi
est-ce un problème pour vous alors
attention c'est pas un problème pour
ceux qui estiment sincèrement qu'il est
impossible de maîtriser le flux
migratoire et que la France devrait
plutôt se préparer à accueillir
davantage c'est le cas de la France
insoumise notamment mais pour ceux qui
revendiquent d'appartenir à une gauche
réaliste celle qui veut de l'humanité
mais aussi de la fermeté le silence ou
les non réponses sont un paradoxe absolu
ah oui alors pourquoi ce paradoxe parce
que précisément en ce moment même un
certain nombre de personnalités ont
constitué une sorte de front anti-ups
pour tenter de sortir les socialistes de
l'orbite de la France insoumise de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon par exemple Bernard
Cazeneuve l'ancien Premier ministre de
François Hollande a lancé le week-end
dernier son mouvement qui s'appelle la
convention et avec d'autres il veut
démontrer qu'il existe un espace
politique pour une nouvelle offre
sociale démocrate mais dans les discours
ce qu'on entend ce sont les thèmes
traditionnels comme la redistribution
des richesses qui domine c'est
indispensable mais ça n'est pas
suffisant on n'entend pas par exemple
parler de l'évolution des partis
sociaux-démocrates du nord de l'Europe
comme la Suède ou le Danemark qui ont
considérablement durci leur politique
d'immigration il pensait que les
sociaux-démocrates français devraient
prendre exemple sur ces pays-là il faut
regarder la réalité en face entre 62 et
70% de Français selon les différents
instituts de sondage estime qu'il y a
trop d'étrangers en France et parmi les
électeurs de gauche ils sont 48%. c'est
énorme c'est donc une donnée que doivent
intégrer tous ceux qui aspirent à la
reconstitution d'une gauche de
gouvernement leur nouvelle offre
politique doit convaincre que cette
gauche-là se saisit des sujets qui
préoccupent une partie une majorité de
la population et qu'elle propose des
solutions contraires concrètes pardon
c'est la solution c'est la condition
sinequanone pour que les citoyens en
quête d'une sociale démocratie
rénovéante qui ne se disent pas il n'y a
rien de nouveau sous le soleil de ce
côté là et qu'au fond il ne s'agirait
que d'une restauration bien compris vous
allez un tout petit beau de réaction si
vous le souhaitez j'ai pas commenté ce
qui se passe au Parti socialiste c'est
de travail avec mon cours je crois je
crois sincèrement qu'en fait il pourrait
aujourd'hui avoir un vrai consensus dans
le pays entre gens de bonne foi sur
cette question parce que voilà nos
capacités d'accueil sont vraiment
totalement saturées on ne sait plus
intégrer les gens c'est plus les
assimilés les conditions d'accueil sont
sont sont indignes quand on voit 100000
environ demandeurs d'asile qui
s'entassent dans des chambres de dans
des centres d'hébergement dans Paris
dans des gymnastes tout ça est
absolument
indigne d'un grand pays comme le nôtre
et oui vous la remettre un petit peu
d'ordre là-dedans je pense que c'est
aussi c'est aussi du bon du bon sens le
consensus pour l'instant on en est très
très loin et un débat apaisé sur
l'immigration bon courage Isabelle on
termine avec vous vouliez revenir sur
cette contre-offensive ukrainienne qui a
été lancé il y a maintenant plusieurs
jours alors elle progresse elle
progresse plusieurs localités
apparemment été reprises dans le sud
elle progresse le secrétaire général de
l'OTAN genstolberg la confirmé
que le patron de Wagner Prigogine qui
concède même aux Ukrainiens une reprise
d'une centaine de kilomètres et pour
l'instant la contre-offensive est assez
symbolique elle vise à tester les
défenses russes à repérer les failles
par où on va passer parce qu'on plus
loin le gros des troupes n'a pas encore
été engagé alors c'est un peu frustrant
pour les occidentaux cette
contre-offensive et sans doute la plus
attendue depuis des dizaines d'années et
en fait on ne sait pas grand chose c'est
normal que du secret le silence
opérationnel les Ukrainiens sont
habitués à annoncer une offensive là et
attaquer de l'autre côté c'est normal
tout va bien pour l'instant c'est le
brouillard de la guerre en quelques mots
les anges je les objectifs de cette
alors les objectifs les objectifs sont
très clairs il s'agit de récupérer
l'intégralité des territoires
Ukrainiens occupés par la Russie donc y
compris la Crimée bien sûr puisqu'elle a
été reconnue en 1991 par la rue en 1994
par plusieurs reprises par la Russie
elle-même les occidentaux suivent les
objectifs d'une manière un petit peu
différente ils disent il faut permettre
aux Ukrainiens de récupérer le plus de
territoire possible afin qu'ils arrivent
en position de force à la table des
négociations alors derrière tout ça il y
a aussi d'autres enjeux qu'on ne voit
pas forcément sur le terrain le premier
enjeu c'est la lutte entre d'un côté les
dictatures les autocraties
représentées par Vladimir Poutine et ses
amis chinois iraniens et autres et de
l'autre côté les démocraties
occidentales enfin l'Occident et le
règne de du droit international et aussi
c'est aussi l'avenir de toute la région
bien sûr pays comme la Géorgie et la
Moldavie qui sont directement concernés
par les résultats de la contre-offensive
et cet objectif de tout reprendre tout
reconquérir possible ou pas alors il est
possible mais sans doute pas tout de
suite les Ukrainiens ne réussiront sans
doute pas à récupérer l'intégralité de
leur territoire à l'issue de 7
contre-offensive la Russie a eu de longs
mois pour se préparer à la construit des
réseaux entiers de fortifications elle a
miné toute la ligne de front et elle
veut aujourd'hui sanctuariser les
territoires conquis pour installer une
espèce de zone grise qui lui permettra
de reprendre la guerre plus tard alors
là dessus il y a deux questions à
laquelle aujourd'hui auxquelles
aujourd'hui personne ne peut répondre
petit un si le régime de Vladimir
Poutine s'effondre ou que l'armée russe
s'effondre évidemment la
contre-offensive ukrainienne ira plus
vite mais que se passera-t-il les
Occidentaux ont peur du chaos et la
deuxième question c'est jusqu'où ira le
soutien des États-Unis est-ce que si la
guerre se poursuit après l'automne
est-ce que les Américains pourraient
franchir électorale la soutiendront
toujours hors l'air d'américaine et le
principe la principale bien sûr
évidemment et heureusement qu'ils sont
là merci vous serez là à vous en tout
cas pour continuer ce qui peut se passer
merci infiniment Isabelle Lasserre il
doit perdre cette guerre Poutine d'un
mot oui non
oui
démocratique allez on s'arrête là je
suis très en retard pardonnez-moi c'est
la fin de cette émission c'est
maintenant Jean-Pierre Gratien qui prend
la main pour une soirée documentaire sur
LCP avec moi demain
[Musique]